[Musique]
depuis la naissance de notre fils il est
hospitalisé
cela était à la cnhi puis il est parti à
l'hôpital de bellepierre
en attendant un diagnostic qui a faim
savoir justement qualité sa pathologie
il nous on avait déjà eu contact avec
une assistante sociale au niveau 2b via
une première histoire sociale
donc vous avez déjà brièvement parlé des
dispositifs qui existent et si c'était
la sécu aussi c'était le département qui
pouvait nous aider donc quelqu'un qui
pouvait intervenir
par la suite on est resté à peu près
deux mois à bellepierre avant de savoir
que un transfert sanitaire de vsphere
[Musique]
la mission première des d'aller chercher
les gens à l'aéroport ensuite on est
conduit dans un hébergement c'est pas de
rousies rouge ça peut être la phrase est
de remettre le parc accueille qui est
constitué d'un plan de paris des tickets
de train pour qui le but lancé jours ici
ensuite un téléphone classique et pas et
après pendant tout le séjour
on a suivi personnalisé en fonction de
ce que la demande de la personne qui est
sûr c'est sûr que ça a été plus
compliqué on est passé par tellement de
m'appeler tellement de monde aussi pour
essayer d'avoir les aider tout ça et
donc s'il y avait pas de bains aurait pu
être là on fait bien sûr tout profit
sans premier temps mais pour elle aussi
laissée seule ici c'est pas possible
mais fallait qu'on soit là tous les deux
[Musique]
ça aurait été plus difficile à gérer que
pour une seule personne et je pense que
pour l'autre personne s'il avait la
séparation il y aurait à séparation a
géré plus bas ce qui se passe ici donc
finalement c'est pas plus mal fois
d'être réunies et en plus du sabin dans
l'étape de la maladie c'est quelque
chose encore plus difficile à vivre que
si on était chacun qui sont cotées
séparer serez pas été facile surtout que
nous c'est un nouveau né donc c'est un
petit bébé donc ce n'est pas par l
attention on doit lui apporter la
présence combat est donné c'est pas
comme un enfant de 10 ans par exemple
non ça se passe bien on est prise en
charge jusqu'au jusqu'à qu'on rentre
chez nous en fait des jalousies orange
et rouge donc les premiers noms savants
on a vu
la mission du rosé rouge je pense que
c'est quelque chose de nécessaire pour
les personnes qui ont besoin d'argent
c'est vraiment un besoin sanitaire
presque sinon les gens sont en
difficulté même financièrement on a
heureusement traille avec la sécurité
sociale aussi quand on a des problèmes
de santé on sait que c'est pas évident
que ce soit la famille
que ce soit les personnes en soins le
fait d'avoir un cadre comme ça où
on ne rentre pas à l'hôtel est d'avoir
un cadre on retrouve des gens on
retrouve une équipe aussi qu'il peut
vous accompagner tout au long des soins
ou de l'accompagnement je pense que
c'est plus que nécessaire le rosé anges
au monde sait que quelques pas on a un
endroit où vivre contrat ou à être
énergie et pas très loin de l'hôpital
novateur par rapport au maître bouclier
assez direct et aussi ça nous permet
justement de savoir que le soir quand
anton à 1 10 ans n'est pas à sous les
pots comme on dit ça on a des bonnes
relations mais conseil départemental on
est vraiment rien qui nous appellent
pour les réservations autre nouvel
établissement et après il ya également
un suivi qui est fait avec le conseil
départemental les personnes de la
réunion qui ont besoin on peut les
appeler ils viennent pour venir les
rencontrer c'est un bon partenariat du
cac donc notre rôle à nous c'est de
faire l'écoutent et nos soutiens ces
personnes coeliaques on va y rendre
visite dans les camps d'hébergement
on voit leurs besoins on les écoute il
ya également numéro vert qui fonctionne
24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 sur
les caniveaux ont appelé pain pour
discuter pour parler de la situation
pour évacuer en fait
[Musique]
venez consulter mail pas facile aux
personnes et la ceni des phobies
département nous les réunionnais une
halle a besoin de sentir la solidarité
il est important de rompre l'isolément
psychologique milieu comme ça que le
malade et prise en charge d'accord mais
il peut pas te l'être tout seul
s'ils aiment unis à l'hôpital il est en
grande difficulté la besoin un membre de
famille qui accompagne livre et nous dit
que c'est une compétence du département
que de faire du social
et c'est pas un mot anglais le social cl
c'est quoi et de se dire comment être
présent dans la vie de tous les jours
par rapport aux gens le département est
fier de pouvoir dire
lyonnaise d'être de la souffrance vous
êtes malade j'ai besoin de soins et dans
le même temps vous n'êtes pas seuls
[Musique]
merci beaucoup c'est gentil déjà porté
ce qui ce qui se passe c'est est ce
qu'ils ont fait pour nous et voilà quand
je n'oublierais pas un pur rapport
maintenant avec nous et ça c'est très
important de la dz donc déjà ça c'est un
bon point positif et c'est quelque chose
qui est donc en plus que un simple un
simple chèque roumazières